there's a statement from the nfl in the
brit reid case and i think it makes
sense to address it here shireen
the
brit reed incident will be investigated
under the personal conduct policy now
the chiefs have already placed brit reed
on administrative leave and one of the
things that you may remember that comes
up when players are in trouble there's
only one track whether it's the league
whether it's the team because of the
collective bargaining agreement it's
very clear that you can't have multiple
penalties one from the league one from
the team
with non-union
employees like coaches they can do
whatever they want the team can take
action the league can take action they
both can take action and it seems like
that is quite possibly what's gonna
happen and over the next month or two
we're gonna learn a lot more about this
and this is just one of those where when
you're in that period of kind of holding
your breath waiting for more evidence
there's enough circumstantial proof
that's already bubbled up in the past
six days that makes me think that what
we ultimately hear
may not be good for brit reed
yeah what a difficult spot andy reid is
in mike i i just can't even imagine how
much hurt he's gone through and you do
wonder how much it affected him and the
preparation for the super bowl and the
decision making that he had in the super
bowl too i don't know if it affected the
rest of the team but i do think it
probably affected andrew i mean how
could it not affect you that's your son
and and you're praying for the kids who
are injured and everything else that
goes with that mike i just can't imagine
the position that andy reads in right
now
yeah and i i just don't think we
appreciate and understand the extent of
the disruption and the distraction that
that caused we talked about that earlier
in the week but that had to have been a
factor how could it not be a factor as a
parent you know how you feel about your
children anyone out there that has kids
and what happens to them happens to you
and every burden that they have is a
burden that you have and when you're
talking about a situation like this
where your child is hospitalized where
your child has had surgery where your
child has potentially been directly
responsible for a serious life-changing
injury on a five-year-old girl how does
that not throw you into a storm of
emotion and turmoil and psychological
torment
and you're three days away from one of
the biggest days of your professional
career and you owe it to your team
to be there you owe it to your team to
do everything you can that's in your
power to help them win
but at your core you're a human being
and andy reid's been through tragedy one
of his other sons died of an overdose
several years ago
that doesn't make it any easier it's
like hey i've been through this before i
know how to deal with these tragedies
each one stands alone each one is
crippling to the parent and you have to
find a way to keep going and i don't i'm
not blaming him i'm not faulting him for
it he's human it had to have affected
him in some way in the run-up to sunday
or in the execution of the game on
sunday night shireen
and mike you look at what's going on in
kansas city over the last week it's been
a terrible week for kansas city i mean
you start with the brit reed incident
last thursday night a week ago and then
obviously the loss in the super bowl
marty schottenheimer dies and then
yesterday we lost therese paler a former
kansas city star rider now with yahoo
who covered the chiefs for years and and
so things have not been pretty in kansas
city over the last week and it's
unfortunate everything that's happened
and you do pray for the kids in the
incident with britt reed and hope they
come out of this alive and in in okay
unanswered questions that eventually
will be answered and the biggest one
unrelated to
the extent of the impairment
and and look we've been around the block
we've heard these stories when someone
tells the cops they've had two or three
drinks what does that really mean right
so they'll do the toxicology we'll get
the information and then the question
will be if there was excessive
consumption where did it happen and when
you have an accident that occurred a
couple of miles away from the team
facility and brit reed resides a half
hour away
on a nine o'clock thursday night i it's
it's you start wondering
frankly
where the consumption occurred and did
the chiefs know or should they have
known that there was an issue like that
right under their noses with all the
surveillance cameras with all the stuff
they have there with all the people who
are around
you just you just wonder
you wonder
what is eventually going to come out and
and uh you know ultimately we hope for
the best health of everyone involved but
uh you know it's it's a serious
situation and the league is clearly
taking it seriously the chiefs are
clearly taking it seriously and uh
you know the the best news out of all
this for the chiefs if there is any as
you move forward you still got patrick
mahomes under contract for another
decade
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports